so by the way by the way like everybody
that hates on me because I cut people
before before you start hating on me
remember you ain't buying [ __ ] yeah
exactly you didn't order anything you
cancelled your order you return the
stuff you hadn't paid for you returning
stuff you didn't need you now making
your car payment you're not making your
house payment how many people is that
cut yeah exactly
I'm paying everyone okay my mortgages I
owe a billion 1.1 billion dollars I pay
my mortgage every month yeah hey my
property taxes every month I pay my
utilities my electric bill I got 500
employees I had a guy when I interviewed
the other day so we didn't cut anybody I
said how many people do you have yeah 15
let's say bro I cut three times more
people than you have employed yeah and I
still have 35 times more people than you
have employed right now hmm so you
didn't cut anybody because you don't
have enough people I heard a very
popular internet guy I haven't let go of
anyone he doesn't have any employees he
has zero employees and he's sitting on
the internet saying I'm fortunate enough
I'm fortunate enough not to have had to
fire anyone bro he don't pay anybody
yeah so Disney Disney's cut a hundred
thousand people
Tilman 40 to cut 45 thousand people I
mean it's all over the place right but
they hire a lot of people too yeah and
you got that what you say if people
aren't going to the hairdresser's about
now then they're following the
hairdresser you have your firing
somebody my wife reminded me about this
mm-hmm
you know so you know we're trying we're
I've given away I've got a charity event
right here in town we funded the entire
charity event we had we had a bunch of
firefighters and policemen in town we
funded all their meals so the
restaurants by the way giving it to the
policemen's one thing that's a nice
thing at all but buying the stuff from
the restaurant because they can't
deliver in the restaurant is keeping
restaurants in business you know 26
million people in the United States were
let go in the last four weeks is if
you're not asking the right questions
you will go in the direction of your
journey
and if you're like I gotta pull over
right now that your journey wasn't to
pull over you were on a journey a month
ago you had dreams and goals and so when
a crisis comes it's like a speed bump
flat tire you ran out of fuel what do
you do you fix you you keep rolling you
fix the tire you refuel and you keep
going and so so don't waste this moment
because we're gonna pass this is gonna
pass yeah your question is and you're
gonna get through it that's the other
thing I keep telling myself like you're
gonna get through this everybody's gonna
get to this Sam the question is when you
get through it on the other side are you
bigger and better more confident more
unstoppable or you're smaller
contracted sports care what sort of
advice would you give to business on
this one now with with a staff with tape
so now you have to be better you've got
to be a better boss in a better leader
the first thing I would suggest that
people do is find out who and what they
need to cut you the cuts really
important the the reason you want to cut
early is because you want everybody that
you're going to stay with to number one
know that how serious your and number
two to properly invest your resources
into people that you can finish the trip
with and maybe you bring those other
people that you cut back later but
you're not bringing anybody back if you
don't make the trip yeah so if I get a
flat tire what do I do
well that charge means so loyal to me I
have to keep it you know it's
interesting how people treat a car
difference in their business yeah you
know dude look I'm on a trip and car
lets me down I'll leave the car on the
side of the road I don't care
get out of the car go get me another car
I'm not invested in that car I'm
invested in my trip you see the
difference I don't care about the tire
now when I say this people think I'm all
cold and everything but I'm committed to
the mission hmm and I know along the way
sometimes you lose people if you're not
losing people
along the way then you're in a fairy
tale you're not that's not a real
business